[Music]
so going to the Republicans for just a
second has Trump in effect crushed the
conservative movement because it seems
to me that the people that are voting
for him they don't really care about
conservative principles they want to win
I think that's a you can make an
argument that that's a perfectly fine
place to place a vote you want to vote
for a winner okay but in terms of
conservative principles this doesn't
have a lot to do with the GOP nominee
right it doesn't but at this point I
mean there's you have to distinguish
between people who voted for him in the
primary which was 35 percent of the or
to 40 percent of the pot of the primary
electorate and meaning 60 percent voted
for somebody else right there was they
were voted for you know a Ted Cruz or
Rand Paul or a Marco Rubio they were
they wanted other somebody else that's
there's all you get the most primary
book and I get that but they were it's
at best a plurality of Republicans of
Republicans supported him in the
primaries then once he becomes the
nominee and and a Republican voter even
a conservative Republican voter has to
choose between him and Hillary it's not
irrational to choose him it's just not
so in a sense the election is about
teams you're rooting figured to you may
not like the quarterback of your team
but you still want your team to win
right right and so people who are
Republicans want their team to win
because they don't like the other team
yeah and yeah really and they and they
might call in the talk in the sports
radio shows to say I wish they'd get rid
of this quarterback but you know what he
is the quarterback so let's win yeah and
I think so I wouldn't tar with the same
brush people who support Trump now that
he's the nominee then people who
supported him to make him the nominee
that's it different that's a different
thing that's a really interesting
distinction because I've seen that
happening where people that were in the
never Trump campaign you know that we're
tweeting about this constantly and
writing articles about it that's slowly
you're seeing them fall in line but
basically you're saying that's just a
natural reaction it's not necessarily
that they're abandoning their principles
but they're saying no matter what he's
better than Hillary if those are the
principles that yeah exactly and and I
don't think it's irrational I don't
think it's irrational to be never Trump
mm-hmm I'm not never Trump I
have I wasn't never Trump all the way
little on but I mean I'm not for Trump
but I'm also not never Trump I don't
think it's irrational be never Trump I
don't think it's irrational to be pro
Trump I don't think it's irrational to
be against Trump I don't think any one
of these are irrational I think
reasonable people can differ now I don't
think that's is true of the primaries
when you had a choice between Trump and
a bunch of other much much better
choices hmm
then I I'm very gown on those people who
opted for Trump then I think they played
into the hands of a con man right I
don't think that was a good move for
them to make so going to that place and
for those couple months you mentioned
you you worked on Rand Paul's campaign
so obviously I assume you wanted Rand
Paul to win than I did and fair to say
what did you think of Ted Cruz because I
would suspect that Ted Cruz a guy was
pretty much as much a constitutionalist
as you're ever gonna get in America now
my issue with him which I said May does
I just he just read as a used-car
salesman to me so even though there were
things that he that he said that I
thought were based in law I didn't like
the guy and I know that's that sort of a
crappy place to be but it is what it is
what did you think of him I I've known
him and I actually I watched him I argue
in the Supreme Court of the United
States he argued a case when he was
Solicitor General of Texas I've mooted
him before he argued I saw him argue in
the Supreme Court he was a brilliant
Supreme Court litigator I met with him
and I think after ran dropped out I
favored him as a Republican over the
other Republicans that were then
available so I actually think quite
highly of Ted I do think that
personality wise he doesn't come across
the way you would want a politician to
be able to come across to appeal to
people I I don't just I met I've
characterized his affect the way you did
as a used-car salesman but I get what
you're reacting to totally and I think
that actually cost him I think that
persona he hasn't got as appealing a
political persona but I do think he has
principles I do think he is in his heart
of heart a conservative I don't think
he's a libertarian but I'll tell you of
all the conservatives I've ever seen run
for office
I think Rand is a libertarian
and of all the Conservatives I've seen
run for office he's the only one who I
saw during his campaign specifically
lists libertarians as people who support
he was seeking respectfully he would
list them libertarians should support me
this people should support me and I've
never seen a conservative Republican
politician favorably appeal to
libertarians like that before and that
tells me something about the guy that I
like yeah so as someone that you know
understands the system understands the
laws that we're governed by and you see
all this and you watch the the primaries
and how it all shook out do you place a
certain amount of blame on the media for
how this whole thing has happened that
Trump didn't run on principles really
but ran on I'm gonna win and I'm gonna
do this via the media and I'm gonna keep
my name out the most and little Marco
and crooked Hillary and lyin Ted and
everything else and I had Scott Adams on
the creator of Dilbert last week and he
really laid out why he doesn't love
Trump the man but he understands what he
did and so do you blame partly just the
media for not making people understand
the way this is all supposed to work
well I can blame the media for almost
everything it's a bit of a deal wide net
there yeah because we're a bit you know
our our political elite are pretty bad
and the media is part of that and and so
the media sure if I had two more specify
who I would blame because I think in
some respects in the mainstream media so
to speak the is predominantly lefty and
and I get that that's sort of like a
given it has been like that my whole
life if I had to blame anyone
specifically it is right-wing media
conservative media talk radio who put
ratings and viewership and popularity
amongst their audience ahead of the
screening and vetting that they formerly
claimed to do I mean they were the ones
that were supposedly down on rhinos
Republican name only is right so who do
they end up you know supporting or at
least legitimating they didn't all
support him Donald Trump but they
legitimated him as a legitimate
conservative when he was in the takeoff
phase a year ago instead of dumping on
him
kept they didn't dump on him and I think
part of it's because some of them were
friends with him personal friends with
him and they should have tried they
essentially legitimated him as a
conservative candidate when they might
have had some influence and by the time
he really took off with the voters they
no longer had the influence and then
they put their audience at risk and then
they got on the bandwagon and so if the
it you know conservative radio
conservative media who was supposed to
be screening people for the
Conservatives I think they fell down on
their job for conservatives right so
they just want they wanted clicks and
views and ratings so they went to where
the clicks and views and ratings are at
one point or another that's what most of
them did it I don't I can't explain them
and I think would probably have to go
down individually by individual why they
did what they did but I was screaming at
you know the radio or the TV saying you
know haha this guy is not for real yeah
and they weren't they weren't they
didn't they weren't prepared to say that
early on yeah so for all the people that
say that Trump is a demagogue and he's
the next Hitler and he's gonna be an
authoritarian and all this stuff do you
think that the underpinnings of our
system are strong enough to withstand
that whether it's Trump or somebody else
do you think that our separation of
powers are actually strong enough to
rein in somebody that could be really
terrible well one of the problems we
have is that our separation of powers
and our constitutional constraints have
been systematically eliminated mm-hmm in
the interest of promoting good
government the government that
progressives have wanted an example of
that well we you know the president has
been Congress has delegated to the
president so much discretionary power by
statute mmm-hmm that it's very difficult
for the to rein in the president when
they wanted when the president in this
case its President Obama wants to do
whatever he wants to do he can usually
point to a statute where Congress has
said it's up to you do what you like so
there have that plus the fact that the
Congress has delegated and I'm and I in
my book our Republican Constitution I
have at least a one chapter on
separation of powers and two chapters on
federalism about how these constraints
on federal power have been
systematically overridden for a long
time for a hunt
years not just recently and as a result
one by one of the checks on the
president's power have been eliminated
and it makes us more vulnerable to an
authoritarian president if we were to
get one it's as though you were flying
on an airplane and you're shutting down
that has a lot of redundant safety
mechanisms built into it right one by
one you're shutting them down and the
plane still is in the air right but your
dish and then now you're down to one
engine and you're still flying right but
if anything were to happen you're in
you've eliminated your redundancy and
the Constitution had a lot of redundancy
built into it that's been eliminated and
now we're kind of on a wing and a prayer
here to stick with my airplane metaphor
yeah and and and hoping there's enough
left to take care of an authoritarian
president should we ever get one I'm not
endorsing the idea that Donald Trump is
necessarily going to be one but yeah
yeah I'm not either I'm but if he is
trying to be then you know we have fewer
constraints on him I do think that
Democrats are going to rediscover the
the the importance of checks on
presidential power if Trump became the
president and just as Republicans have
rediscovered checks on presidential
power with Obama in office that they
weren't as enamored with when Bush was
there right so they all sort of have
principles when it's convenient right
like they suddenly oh well the
Republicans are gonna say we don't want
executive actions when it's a Democratic
president and vice versa right I mean I
don't want to play the game of moral
equivalence and say everybody's always
the same as everybody else but the
there's a term called Fairweather
federalism Federalists
you're a Fairweather Federalist when you
know you're against the national policy
and you want so therefore you prefer
four states but if you're for the
national policy you're not so big on
states I think this is a tag that you
can easily attach to Republicans as well
as Democrats easily okay so as the
executive branch gets more powerful is
there any instance where you think the
executive order or the executive action
first of is there a difference between
an executive order and executive action
executive orders are actually literally
orders issued by the President to
subordinate members of the executive
branch to do X Y & Z executive action is
a broader category of thing
that the executive branch is going to do
so it's it's fudge is it it fudges up
what used to be an executive order is a
specific thing the president orders the
second of Department of Health Education
and Welfare to do this we're the
secretary of that to do that it's an
actual order hmm executive action as
here's what we and the executive branch
are going to do about such and such a
problem we're going to do this we're
going to take executive action right so
it's a fuzzier concept right so
constitutionally the executive action is
the one that you'd be more leery of
right because it's sort of vaguer and
the flowers are no I'm not necessarily I
mean executive orders first of all the
president if you believe in a unitary
executive where the president's at the
top and you have people subordinate to
him the executive should be able to
issue orders to his subordinates to do X
Y & Z so there's nothing inherently
wrong with an executive order nor is
there anything inherently wrong with
saying we and the executive branch are
going to do the following as our actions
the question is are they authorized to
do it by law right or are they trying to
get around the law either trying to get
around a law or trying to avoid going to
Congress for something that really ought
to get authorization from Congress to do
match the problem it's that it's not the
bare existence of an executive order but
it's what they're trying to do with
executive orders and it's what
presidents have been doing for a while
and as I said earlier mostly what they
do they they can justify doing by the
discretion that Congress has given them
in innumerable statutes where Congress
has dropped the ball and said you do
what you like right
and then when they turn around and start
doing what they like and everybody gets
upset but then Congress can't stop them
from doing it without having another law
that the president is going to have to
sign and they won't sign so now Congress
having given up discretion to the
executive branch can't reclaim that
power without the cooperation of the
President and that's not going to happen
so it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
sort of Congress doesn't do anything
they give the executive branch the power
the executive branch uses the power then
they get upset but you've already you've
just created this mechanism that will
just kind of keep right well in in my
book I do talk about why it was the
progressives hit upon the administrative
state which
is all in the executive branch to
essentially make the laws of the country
they have out Congress's outsourced the
lawmaking power by and large to
executive branch agencies by saying we
want clean air we want clean water you
go make the rules for that now the rules
for that are what used to be called laws
telling us what to do right now now
being made by executive branch agencies
and many some of them are at least
theoretically subject of presidential
controls some of them are independent of
presidential control and and Dave and
they did that because they couldn't pass
enough laws I mean I
there's 535 of them right they can't
pass enough laws to satisfy the
progressives so they needed to outsource
the lawmaking power and then all you
have to do is hire more administrators
and you can make as many laws as you
like right so okay so let's get to your
book a little bit and let's talk about
progressives a little bit too so the
progressives basically they couldn't get
certain things done so it really it
becomes about authoritarianism for them
right like they need to get things done
and they can't do it through the
legislative process and that's why
they're pushing this well there was a
limit we have a government that was
designed to be limited and so if you
want to do a lot more if you want to be
a lot more ambitious then you have to
get around the limits and they were then
very ingenious over a long period of
time and the progressives that I'm
talking about in my book our Republican
Constitution are the original
progressives they were the progressives
in the late 19th century early into the
20th century they include Republicans
like Teddy Roosevelt and Democrats like
Woodrow Wilson Republicans like Herbert
Hoover Democrats like FDR they were
there were all progressives and they
believed they had a very affirmative
ideology that said government needs to
be much more active it needs to be doing
things in the public welfare but they
were using what they themselves called a
horse-and-buggy Constitution to try to
get there so they basically adopted what
they called living constitutionalism to
evolve out of that and they did all
these workarounds to get out of the
constraints well one of the constraints
is that all legislative power according
to the Constitution should reside in a
Congress of the United States that's now
535 people right now before air
conditioning they could only sit there
some
now they got air-conditioning so I can
sit there twelve months but it's only
535 people they can only make so many
laws well to run the whole economy to
run the whole country they need a lot
more laws than 535 people can pass so
they actually outsource it to the
administrative agencies and then
progressives could monitor the
administrative agencies by how much they
funded them without having to actually
make any more laws and they insulated
them from presidents who might get
elected by other parties and so they're
really out there doing their own thing
and and that was a way that they could
make as many laws as progressives wanted
to see made in my book I basically
proposed two major reforms that would to
limit the size of government based on
the original Constitution and one is
that most all of the big issues should
be decided by state governments rather
than the federal government so that you
can have a diversity of fifty state
solutions to different social and
economic problems the other one is that
the Congress should make its own laws so
the radical my radical proposal is yeah
that it's not that no government should
do anything but that state governments
of which there could be more choices
should do more and the federal
government should do less and secondly
that the lawmaking the elected lawmakers
should make all the laws that's I know
that's right you're giving me something
out there yeah yeah those who were
elected to be lawmakers right should
make them should make all the laws I
know that is radical radical stuff do
you think the concept of states rights
has been totally lost too it seems like
we debate everything on a federal level
now and I guess this is exactly what
you're saying we've gotten to the point
where we think the executive branch has
all this power so we think that the
president can magically do everything
and we forget that the states are
supposed to do most of the things that
should have to do with our day to day
life should be decided right but I don't
like the term states rights first of all
the Constitution is very fastidious the
only rights that it refers to our our
rights right what government has our
powers and their delegated powers
governments are our agents government is
a fiduciary working on our behalf and
ultimately subject to the control of the
voters but still they're producer
so they have powers and we have rights
and the states rights theme which is
very old
yeah and it's easy to think of to use
right I don't like the term because so
you and you what term would you both
know there's state there's no state
discretion state lawmaking diversity of
states there's lots of ways to talk
about it I don't think states have
rights per se although truthfully
relative to the federal government you
can say they do have rights but I just
prefer the term rights be used for us
there the term powers be given to them
powers are good enough they got powers
that that should be they should be
satisfied with that my audience knows I
like terms so I'm okay with some
definitions okay that makes sense but
but so you would agree though that we
have slowly eroded that to the point
that it that it almost it doesn't seem
that anyone cares about the powers that
the state is supposed to well here's the
thing
states are bad actors state government
all governments can do bad things state
governments can do bad things you know
Clint Bolick who's now a Supreme Court
justice in Arizona wrote a book called
grassroots tyranny because of the
terrible things that local people
governments do I'm I'm for that
the thing about local governments or
state governments is you have 50 of them
they tend to compete with each other for
resources for businesses and for
population as a result there are some
constraints on them that are not at the
national level because of those
constraints progressives long ago
decided they wanted everything done at
the national level because the option if
they were to win at the national level
is to stay in this country or leave your
country if you lose in something at the
state level you can go across the state
line either as an individual or as a
business right they didn't like that
that was too much of a constraint on
what governments could do so that's
really fast so push everything to the
national level and then you have to
leave your country to get to another
legal system and there might not be
anything better and people are reluctant
to do that so I'm for the orig
and we still have the mentality if
you're really serious about something
you must support a federal law not a
state law but a federal law right that's
serious
that's serious meaning one size fits all
for three hundred and some-odd million
people rather than a diversity of
approaches where Texas can do one
thing Wyoming you can do something
California can do something where we are
today California or or DC everybody can
do different things and there's a
different mix and people will flow to
where they like it better yeah that's
actually the best explanation of when I
say when I describe progressives as
authoritarians now that's really the
best example of that because you could
take something like the New York State
at state tax which is probably lower
than Florida so a lot of people
eventually older people leave New York
and they go to Florida the progressives
because they want a certain tax level to
be high for those people in New York
well then they want it to be federal now
you can't go to Florida so then you'd
really have to literally leave the
country right that shows why it's about
power really yeah so I have a chapter of
the book all about this and I and I
talked about foot voting which a
colleague of mine a friend of mine at
George Mason University
Elias Olman has a book about federalism
in which he talks about foot voting I
like the term where which can you do
more to advance your own personal
well-being electoral voting in the
ballot box where you're one of millions
or foot voting where you actually have
it within your power to uproot yourself
and move across now people say well but
if people don't move people have been
moving all the time in fact the South
had to pass laws that prohibited labor
agents from coming down and recruiting
blacks to go north to work in better
locations because blacks were fleeing
the south to live in the north once they
after the Civil War
that's how mobile we are now not
everybody can move but people really are
able to move and if that's something you
can do to improve your life going to the
ballot box every two years every four
years and checking off a name that's not
going to do that much super improve your
life so people are a lot more pay a lot
more attention to how they can improve
their lives that way because they
actually if they take action the action
will have consequence right they take
action they may close a small business
they take all their money out of the
local economy and they will actually
yield a benefit by going somewhere
whereas by if they go to the ballot box
and they pull the lever they may or may
not get any benefit from that so they
take that first decision much more
seriously and that provides a much
bigger constraint on what governments
can do because if they lose their voters
they lose their businesses then they're
you know they're
to be more constrained not perfectly
constrained again I also favor in the
book federal under the Fourteenth
Amendment federal scrutiny of state laws
that are irrational and arbitrary and
how they restrict our liberties the
federal the Fourteenth Amendment does
give the federal government power to
protect us from our own states something
they didn't have before the Civil War in
the original founding and I talk a lot
about that as well but that's sort of a
third line of defense so first you have
most of the power stays at the states a
few things functions go to the federal
government at the federal government
level you have separation of powers to
try to keep it on the level and then
when the states go haywire
you have the ability to go to federal
court to protect your liberties from
your own state government acting
irrationally and arbitrarily that's what
my book proposes as the way the system
should work right and all of that is
within the way the system is supposed to
work right you're not you're not calling
for something that would alter the
system really if I had a copy of the
Constitution now I could hold up as a
prop I would say I'm only calling for
the this thing the law that governs of
them who govern us to be followed right
that's all I'm proposed so you're not
saying passed an amendment to do this
you're not saying well I do propose some
amendments at the end of the book and I
proposed more amendments in my last book
called the Bill of federalism which are
attempting to restore the basic
operation of the Constitution both
against Court decisions which have
undermined it but also there are ways in
which amendments to the Constitution
have messed things up we have you know
states no longer have the input they
used to have when they could select
their own senators by legislatures and
they and there's the income tax which
has created an enormous amount of wealth
in Washington that they used to bribe
States to do what they want to have done
so there are some things we could do by
amendment to make the Constitution
better at the margin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]